[Music]
you gotta know what the gun don't know
how you're gonna do it the Bastille is
pretty oh no a compliment he a woman
disguised herself as a man to get
working to she was a cute right Oh
thousand woman written so that's not
what happened
okay so they do it in jail all the time
what they rape them psychologically yeah
that's how women rape each other are you
making that up
no they do it with the finger and then
they do all kinds of stuff and I don't
want to do it but like oh yeah I don't
care I'm gonna do it to you
that's what rape is that's crazy because
it's like I don't know nevermind what do
you think is fishy no cuz I'm just
thinking like uh when a guy I don't know
anything about rape you're not an expert
that's okay I'm not I don't know but I'm
sorry I don't know other for me I tell
me if you want a guy's ripping a girl
you're getting some sort of pleasure
because there's a BEC Dominus hmm well
that and then I mean whose dick has
feeling so he's alive still
yeah right really motion but then when a
woman is doing it to a woman and using
her hand it's just pure dominance and
it's just like that they're getting off
of the dominance there's no actual
physical relief yes I'm like oh that's
crazy that's well sing they're
scissoring each other pal pal yeah papa
and they're creating like the the
friction to create a fire rug burn there
you go
so this story is about policing that was
not what I was expecting at all and
that's it through me all like Paul
Mooney he's a comedian he's a writer but
you be oh yeah I could everyone knows
him now because of the work on mr. broy
yeah yeah oh she's the old OG comedian
writer that was my introduction mr.
Peschel
yeah so that p me she's first focus
should give that out
please from Tanzania and so she's saying
that she was the daughter of my life Sox
keeper growing up and that's why she
bought Jessie her father had six wives
and she was one of 38 children yeah he's
been [ __ ] a lot
yeah and so she's saying that her father
treated her like a boy growing up she
was always given livestock to take care
of because he forgot who she was 38 how
do you track of 38 kids in okay that's
so [ __ ] weird because out here if you
have 38 kids you're going to be poor and
have zero time for yourself but out
there you can have 30k kids and it's
totally cool
you might even become rich because you
have all these soldiers working on your
farm taking care of the livestock on Wow
yeah so then she's saying that she end
up getting married she was very unhappy
in her marriage that at the age of 31
P Lee ran away from her abusive husband
and so she was looking for work where
she was looking for Richard in this
really small town which is like at the
foothills of Kilimanjaro which is
Africa's highest mountain and so they're
saying that this place is the only place
in the world where you can mine for a
rare violet blue gemstone called
tanzanite and so that's where she
decided that she would pose as a man
because women never go into the mind she
was close as a man in order to make
money and so then people started calling
her or she had people start calling her
uncle Huseyin so it was what she was
known as she said that it was really
easy for her to act like a man because
she just had to be like roots and I just
thought it'd be that for you yeah she
just had to cut some shorts up and she
was like and then you just take some big
trousers cut them up to into shorts and
they you here as a man how does that
easy
yes she's also big-boned oh yeah yeah
she super flexy could be on linemen
she looks ambiguous you know like if she
didn't have issued as she didn't have
that off and on I wouldn't know if it's
like you're charging
yeah yeah yeah so they're saying like
she entered the work feels like like a
brave man and she was able to do a lot
of the work that other men can't even
knew Oh
Thank You Riley she looks like a really
dark Chinese person in that picture this
is Alexis tanzanite God look at her
hands and they're saying they're like a
hundred times more rare than diamonds ah
so what is the purpose for those
gemstones do you know it's like diamond
like jewelry yeah it just looked like
black glass that's like what the mines
look like and I'm yeah she's saying like
she was able to she would be going
600 meters down into them into the mines
like holy moly never go anywhere near
the mines first things but not little in
that far
yeah she's saying that uh but not all
women are the same
she's tough she was born to be a mother
[ __ ] stone
yeah she's saying that she would work 10
to 12 hours a day digging and Stevie
hoping to uncover these like gemstones
and so finally she was able to really
struck a big one time and she was able
to buy a lot of home for a lot of her
family members here she's able to pay
for she's a boss yeah she was able to
pay for like a lot of her nieces
education like night nieces and nephews
she should be in the USD yep she's too
old for that now your [ __ ] well I mean
work is the rape coming to all this like
who she try to [ __ ] yeah so then she
wasn't especially in that outfit and a
rush the story okay keep going table
it's hard to rape people in alpha like
that they can see you coming a mile away
it's just looking like a gold foil tell
us what happened anyways then she got
all this money we uh she was able to
hire minors to work for her so then she
was able to get even more money
so anyways there was at one time once
the police went to the mines where the
men worked and they were inquiring about
the fact that this woman was claiming
a man from the mines raped her so then
she's saying that the man who actually
raped that woman pointed purely out that
is funny and said that's the man that
raped her
oh what a big man she [ __ ] up I'm
actually a woman she [ __ ] up so then
that's when the police took her into the
station or whatever and then that's when
she asked like in a woman physically and
examine me because I can prove to you
that it wasn't me so that's what they
did and she was able to prove that I
have a [ __ ]
laughs surprise huh gotcha [ __ ] be
[ __ ] yeah unless she's been like once
the police went back to the mines and
said oh it wasn't that prison because it
turns out that she's a woman no one
would believe it they're like no way no
I'm comparing it with the huggable ha ha
ha
[ __ ] uncle Hussein is a [ __ ] woman
kick my ass yesterday no cuz since um
like for over a decade she was
masquerading to be a man
damn I'm thinking yeah so then that's
when they were like that would be
unbelievable yes especially as she was
beating all the dudes that all the dudes
like do tasks yeah a lot of men were
even afraid to do a lot of his work
issue they would have killed her that
yeah yeah so luckily like her name was
cleared
I found the rapist um nothing your
question they didn't what if that girl
just made it up to make money know what
she did point out the fact that the man
who actually did rape that woman pointed
her out to be the rapist so there was a
rape that happened oh yes she's just
telling her story because she is part of
the UN Women mapping study on gender and
extractive industries in mainland
Tanzania so that's how she was featured
like her story was told don't hope for
her yeah but pretty close sure they
would fool so many men and actually kept
up with them and she even hired your own
miners yeah thought oh oh no no I should
be dead lift I know I want to put
through the ringer there that does
naturally how strong she is yeah Polly
strong
[ __ ] yeah I don't I don't really care
about the whole like is the gender right
for the job I think is the person yeah
for the job because like if you have
like a dainty 4 foot girl that comes in
and goes I'm a woman I could do whatever
I want but it's like did you grow up on
the farm are you tough can you do this
stuff like it's not about you being a
woman or whatnot it's about you having
the actual skill set and ability like
uncle Huseyin over here who's like
you've been built and ready for this
[ __ ] when you know a lot of these guys
probably like they can't hang because
they didn't grow up like her the size of
her [ __ ] hands dude they're huge
I trust all I trust her to be my
bodyguard I trust her to be like my
bodyguard my protector like I if I pick
anybody out of this cloud and be like
who wants to you know [ __ ] go into
the jungle and survive I pick her beyond
anybody I think if I had a farm partner
that's why I'm picking you know I don't
go lardo actually look comfortable as
hell trying to give me ideas oh my god
well her outfit
yeah it should a [ __ ] comfortable man
I could 1990s Curtin patient exactly
looks like it looks like folks know that
70 showed or something like that
Oh what did she know um I'm not sure I
was trying to look for her age too
didn't really report her age she was she
would be busy like a hippie
she just looks strong man and even under
sixty would be right what if you had
done like your ass beat by like my gosh
who you thought I would it wouldn't hurt
my pride because I think um if you're
comfortable with who you are you're not
you're value isn't based off of being
out competed by anything so for example
like even if I got my ass beat by a
child it's kind of like you deserve to
win yeah I didn't train enough or I
didn't do enough
it's not magic it's not luck it's like
you know that's what God's love a great
equalizer on stage I'm not gonna get my
husband my girl I got a good yeah there
you go beat my ass
cut that [ __ ] out there you can never
have a gun I know ever that's like if
Ronda Rousey beats your ass and it's
like dog that's her life career that's
her [ __ ] like of course she's gonna beat
my ass yeah but can I out funny her you
got in there yo here's here's this
though did you hit so people are reading
a couple comments on the internet right
and you know Michael Jai White yeah
martial artists go back to he's gay so
he was asked a question on this radio
show he goes who could be Bruce Lee who
knows me and then word that's a bold
statement yeah and then he was basically
saying she goes what do you mean he goes
I have a hundred pounds on him and I'm a
trained martial artist like size does
matter at a certain point through but
then everybody in the comments were
saying like no way Bruce Lee would
[ __ ] whoop your ass
easy I'm like I know Bruce Lee is a
great guy but it's not like Michael Jai
White isn't a trained martial artist as
well yeah and he's also a hundred pounds
heavier and he has crazier reached yep
so it's you know he is 130 so event now
yeah Michael Jai White is a football
player that's a martial artist yes a
high high level martial artist yeah and
then well Reno's comments like you do
you think Michael Jai White's [ __ ]
slow have you seen that for hit he's
[ __ ] him fast he may not be as fast as
Bruce Lee in his prime you know what I'm
saying
but he's in the same weight class yeah a
hundred pounds more
he literally weighs 100 pounds more you
know the huge possibility that had Bruce
Lee even hit him it might not even hurt
him very much it's because Bruce Lee
just doesn't have like if you saw 130
pounds at someone it's just not that
much weight yeah
and Michael jy is a coaching guy he has
a lot of she's heard a full-contact
experience where yeah Lucy did spar but
I'm going to say anything else that was
it leave it at back hey guys I hope you
enjoyed that episode of just kidding
News and if you guys want to share a
story there's a link down in the
description box below where you can
submit your story if you guys want to
watch more episodes click right up here
you
[Music]